Speaker 1: Despite the American right wing
claiming that the left is indoctrinating children
through critical race theory and left wing
university courses, it is actually the right
wing that is indoctrinating children now.
We have this recent example from Florida where
Ron DeSantis and the Florida Board of Education
banned and an advanced placement.
Every time I see AP, I think Associated Press
banned an advanced placement Black History
course because they claim that it contains
queer theory and indoctrination and things
that should not be in such a course.
Now, yesterday I talk to you about how absurd
this is and the fact that this is not a required
course.
This is actually it's not even elective.
It's an elective advanced placement course.
And if you think about it as a college equivalent,
college courses regularly have more niche
topics of interest to the people that want
to take the course.
You don't have to take it anyway.
It was all absurd, but this is an example
of the right claiming we are working very
hard to stop the left from indoctrinating
our kids.
But the reality is that the propaganda of
child indoctrination is overwhelmingly from
the right.
Here is the latest propaganda being promoted
by Mike Huckabee.
This was this came on during a commercial
break on Fox Business.
It is promoting the Kids guide to Fighting
Socialism, which you can get at socialism
stinks.
Dot com.
We've spoken before about the president Trump
kids guide from it looks like the same organization
because Huckabee promotes it and like the
font looks the same.
This is the Free Kids Guide to President Trump,
which will allow children to learn about President
Trump's accomplishments in office.
President Trump's vision for America and how
President Trump's policies are right for America.
This is straight up for kids.
This is not the type of thing I want to teach
kids, which is, Here's how you think for yourself.
Here's how you can determine whether you are
reading something that is true or false.
That's what I want to teach kids.
Okay.
That's not what the Trump Kids Guide for Children
teaches them.
In 2017, the Trump administration proposed
cutting funding for afterschool programs that
provided a safe and positive environment for
children.
And instead they redirected that money to
religious organizations and groups that promote
conservative value.
That is the right funding, the right's indoctrination
of children.
But they say it's the left that does it.
In Texas, the State Board of Education has
promoted a conservative agenda in state schools.
They promoted the teaching of creationism,
the downplaying of the role of slavery in
the civil war to children.
That is right wing indoctrination of kids
in Arizona.
The State Board of Education approved a curriculum
that promotes a conservative pro-Trump agenda,
and it downplays the contributions of minorities
and marginalized groups in American history.
In Idaho, a school board member promoted the
teaching of Bible courses in public school
and said We should be teaching creationism
alongside evolution.
In West Virginia, the state's Department of
Education promoted a conservative agenda in
public schools, including promoting coal mining
and downplaying the role of climate change
in their educational standards.
I'll give you one more example.
In Oklahoma State Board of Education promoted
a conservative agenda and approved textbooks
that present a conservative perspective on
American history and on government.
They say the left indoctrinate children.
They are actually the ones that do it.
So what is it that we can do?
All the things we talk about?
You've got to be involved with school boards.
You've got to be involved with education issues
at the local, state and federal level.
And we have to fight against the idea that
teaching kids critical thinking is liberal
indoctrination.
And this is something that is unfortunately
becoming widespread.
When you talk to conservatives, many not all,
when you talk to some conservatives and say
we should really be teaching critical thinking
when kids are ten, 11, 12, we should be teaching
media literacy, we should be doing all these
things.
Many of these right wingers say that's liberal
indoctrination, but of course it's not.
The the reality, though, is that if more kids
knew how to think for the.
Themselves.
If more kids knew how to think critically,
if more kids knew how to suss out whether
messages they were being given in the media
are true or false, or are trying to convince
them of something that isn't true.
It is true that it would hurt the conservative
movement.
Fox News relies on having an uninformed audience
where they turn on the TV and Tucker Carlson
says, See this floating space vagina, which
is just a cloud?
You should be scared of that.
And then the audience goes, Yeah, I should.
Whereas an audience that is more media literate
and that is more well versed in critical thinking
wouldn't fall for that.
So I've mentioned this before.
We are very, very close to publishing a kids
book on critical thinking.
This is going to be quite literally an illustrated
children's book.
I've been saying for years and years and years
there need to be better materials and more
materials for teaching kids this stuff early.
We are doing it.
We are almost done with the text of the book.
We are trying to get the illustrations finalized
and set up the printing of the book, etc.
We are sort of putting our money where our
mouth is and we are going to be publishing
such a book.
It's going to be fantastic.
A couple of people already reached out and
said, David, when you do this, I'm buying
100 copies and I'm going to send them.
I'm going to bring them to libraries in my
area.
This is super, super exciting and I'm glad
to be doing it.
And I'll have more information for you about
it very, very soon.